نعود الان الى الخبر العاجل الذي اوردناه
قبل قليل والذي افاد به مراسل الجزيره لان
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تطلق النار على
منفذ عمليه الدهس شرقيه رام الله بعد
مطاردته
وسائل الاعلام
بعض
الصور من مكاني وقوعها حيث تظهر
القوات الاسرائيليه وهي تحيط بالمكان
وتفرد اجراءات الامنيه مشدده ويبدو ان
هناك نقاط امنيه لتفتيش السيارات العابره
كما يبدو ربما بحثا عن المنافقين
[موسيقى]
سنعود الان يبدو من
يتابع الخبر وينضم الينا
حول هذه العمليه التي تابعنا اخبرها عبر
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه قبل قليل وتاب
على الصور من عيني المكان ويبدو انتشار
القوات الاسرائيليه
وتوقيف عدد من السيارات بحثا عن منافذ
العمليه الذي ما زال تطارده القوه
الاسرائيليه كما يبدا الياس قالت ايضا
السلطات انها اطلقت النار عليه
نعم المعلومات الاوليه تشير الى ان شابا
فلسطينيا كان يقود سياره على الشارع
الالتفافي الواصل ما بين مدينه القدس
ومدينه رام الله وتحديدا قرب مستوطنه كخاف
يعقوب الواقعه الى الشرق من مدينه رام
الله حيث قام بتنفيذ عمليه دهس وفقه
ادعاءات الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مما
ادى الى اصابه مجنده توصف جراحها بحسب
المصادر الطبيه الاسرائيليه بانها ما بين
خطيره
ومتوسطه منفذ العمليه وفقه شهود العيان
فره من المكان اا باتجاه المناطق الشماليه
من موقعه حدوث العمليه اي باتجاه منطقه
همم حاجز الارتباط الواقع الى الشرق من
مدينه رام الله حيث قامت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وشرطه الاحتلال في تلك او
المنطقه بنصب الحواجز ومطاردته على
الشوارع المؤديه في المنطقه يا شوارع
رئيسيه تحديدا الشارع الالتفافي الرابط
بين رام الله والقدس من الجانب الشرقي اا
وهناك تم كما يبدو وفق شهود عيان ضبط منفذ
العمليه حيث قام جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باطلاق وبلا من الرصاص باتجاهيه حتى هذه
الساعه لم ترد ايه انباء حول حاله الحاله
الصحيه لمنفذ العمليه او الجراح التي اصيب
بها لكن واضح من ان المعلومات في الجانب
الاسرائيلي تتحدث عن تحييد منفذ هذه
العمليه وهو المقصود عمليا همم بقتله او
اصابته على الاقل بجروحا خطيره للغايه هذه
العمليه تاتي في اطار تصعيدا واضح وصريح
واضح المعالم في الايام الماضيه وفي
الساعات الاخيره على وجه الخصوص وهنالك
تحذيرات في جانب الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي يقول بان هذه العمليات من
شانها ان تتواصل تشهد تصعيدا في قادم
الايام الجيش الاسرائيلي نشر بالامس
احصائيات حول
مستوى العمليات التي شهدها هذا العام
وتحديدا منذ انطلاقه عمليه كاسر الامواج
التي اطلقها في الربيع الماضي وقال بان
العمليات الفلسطينيه التي نفذ ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه بلغت ثلاثه اضعاف ما كانت عليه
في العام الماضي وهو اشار الى ان عدد هذه
العمليات همم تجاوزت 2008 عمليه في ارجاء
الضفه الغربيه المحتله وكذلك في داخل همم
الخط الاخضر في المدن الاسرائيليه همم
الكبرى كما اشار جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في هذه الاحصائيات الى ان اعتداءات
المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين وعلى
ممتلكاتهم العامه تضعف على الاقل مره
وبلغت هذه الاعتداءات اكثر من 800 اعتداء
على الفلسطيني سنكون معك في المتابعه على
ما يكون هناك جديد يس كرامه اشكرك اياس
كرم وكنت معنا من القدس